[Music]
our last speaker today is Michael lesk
and to tell you a bit about why he is
here as you know Memex was a personal
information organization and retrieval
mechanism and whereas Michael is
probably known to you as one of the
original UNIX hackers for example Lex
and yak and uucp the real reason for his
being here is that he's a deep scholar
equally at home in the humanities and in
computer science where he's been
specializing in information retrieval
he's the chief research scientist at
Bell core he's also visiting professor
at the University of College University
College in London where he
simultaneously holds appointments in
computer science and librarianship and
he's had an abiding interest in books
and libraries Michael thank you very
much of all the undeserved praise I will
in particular correct that I did not
write yak but I'm very flattered to be
here and I thank you I'm going to talk
the talk title of this talk is the seven
ages of information retrieval if we
could have the first slide Shakespeare
wrote about the seven ages of man and
information retrieval we think of it as
being born in 1945 I think it's gonna
work out very well to view it as a human
life that ie by the time that it would
be say 70 in 2015 we will be done we
will have achieved with Bush set out -
we will have a library of a million
books fitting into your desk at least
virtually to show you how far along we
are on this everyone in the audience
think the last time you needed to know
something that you had to look up you
didn't remember it and the guy in the
next office didn't know how did you look
it up on a screen or on paper how many
on a screen raise your hand and how many
on paper raise your hand last time okay
about 75 80 percent on screens hands
that that is how far we have come and I
can easily believe that in the next 20
years we'll get the rest of the way so
I'm going to talk about IR as a life
with its seven stages this works
particularly well for me because I was
born in 1945 and so I think of this
right you know when you know IR was 20
years old and should have been in you
know sort of college student changed the
universe mode well you know I was
working for Jerry salt then we were
publishing the first paper about smart
and C ACM and trying to introduce read
text indexing so it works well enough
the other comment I will use as a thread
through the talk is there's been a
tension throughout this life we've heard
a lot about Bush now in addition to
Professor Bush Bush
there was another MIT man named Warren
Weaver who was active at the same time
Weaver wrote an article in 1949
recommending machine translation Bush
remember is alluding in his article to
the work of the physicists the people
who built the nuclear bomb and the
microwave radio Weaver who was another
MIT man another propeller had gone out
from Cambridge to rule the world was
thinking in terms of the cryptographers
the people who had broken codes with
computers during the war he thought of
well we could use that technology on
language he said quote it is very
tempting to say that a book written in
Chinese is simply a book written in
English which was coded into the Chinese
code if we have useful methods for
solving almost any cryptographic problem
may it not be there with proper
interpretation we already have useful
methods for translation so which started
hypertext and information retrieval
we were started machine translation but
there's also attention to you Bush
thought of information organization as
people will make trails analogous to the
manual indexers who have been working in
libraries for generations
Weaver is talking about statistics and
throughout the life of information
retrieval there has been this tension
between are we going to do intellectual
analysis whether it be manual or
automatic or are we going to sort of do
word counting it's exactly the same
tension that exists in chess between the
people who say we'll try all legal moves
as far ahead as we can and those who say
no no no there must be a role for
intelligent selection of which moves to
evaluate and in the same way we have
this tension in IR for its entire
history so ok we'll go through this and
say in 1945 field starts Shakespeare's
next stage is the schoolboy which would
have been in the 60s then adulthood
experience Shakespeare actually goes on
to things like soldier and justice and
comic character on the stage I only do
those so we've changed them a little bit
bushes bushes predictions are rather
interesting if we could have the next
slide please this is a list of some of
the things Bush said we were going to
have and it will not be unfamiliar to
everybody in the business that most of
the technology predictions were achieved
at some point we have instant
photography in fact we had it very soon
after he wrote we have motor driven
cameras and we have automatic exposure
cameras we have computers that have
Cardon film control and select their own
data what don't we have well we haven't
actually achieved his storage goals we
can't put a million volumes in a desk
yet although me data center has the
equivalent of a million volumes they
have 2.6 terabytes but that's it's a
very selected set of stuff we don't have
speech recognition we don't have really
working OCR and some of the things that
were done turned out not to be worth
doing stereo photography has been
achieved but it's sort of a toy to sell
to tourists and the ultra microfiche was
held up earlier today again was achieved
but if you're a librarian and let's say
out of each hundred dollars of your
budget you spend $25 on the building and
somebody tells you that regular
microfiche would reduce that cost to $5
and you don't do it it's unlikely that
telling you the
Ultra microfiche will reduce the cost to
$2 will make enough of a difference
reducing 100-125 down to a hundred and
five doesn't cut it down to one hundred
and two isn't going to cut it either so
we again we've done most of the hardware
stuff we're still waiting on some of the
software stuff we haven't got automatic
typing from dictation we haven't got OCR
we also by the way haven't got the stuff
about plugging your nerves directly into
electronic systems although I did see a
paper our story on that in the newspaper
fairly recently what I found more
interesting was that Bush talked a lot
about individualized systems the way
Bush envisioned his interface each
person would have their own personalized
information space for most of the
history of information retrieval that
isn't what's been done what's been done
is to have systems that look the same to
everybody who uses them and which
therefore provide the best access to the
information that is sort of impersonal
the journal articles but again that's
that's something we'll come back to
later so let's go and we still have this
infancy stage now in 1957 the Soviet
Union put up the first artificial Earth
satellite and that produced a wide array
of fears that the United States was
falling behind in science and a
realization that the United States
didn't even know much about what was
going on in Russian science so there was
some funding of Russian language studies
and machine translation and there was a
lot of funding of information transfer
to say well well the answer will be that
we'll improve our knowledge by building
systems to distribute information there
were widespread urban legends of some
company that had spent either $100,000
or 250 thousand dollars to reproduce a
result that had been readily available
in the literature but they had not found
I once
eventually saw a paper in which someone
claimed that they had run this story to
the ground and it was false but it was
widely believed at the time so people
set to work the first thing they did was
they built quick indexes I don't know
how many
keyword in context indexes man named HP
wound if you think that's primitive you
should remember what the competition was
how many people here remember something
called edge notch punch cards a
reasonable number for the you know I
thought about bringing one and then I
said where am I going to find an edge
knotch card today so I made some and the
idea for those of you haven't seen them
is you have these cards and you can you
know have these a row of holes and you
can hold them up with something through
the holes and let's say this is a
bibliography so this card has the
citation for Moby Dick and this card has
a citation for principles of computer
graphics and you take each hole and you
would sign it so let's say that we
decide that this hole is going to be
books written by Andy Van Dam so for
this card we tear out that notch and
let's say the next hole is books written
by Al a hole we haven't got one of those
and let's say the next one is going to
be books written by Jim Foley so again
we'll make a notch and let's say that
somewhere we get to Herman Melville and
make it and now you see we have this
batch of cards and again you can put
something through the slots and suppose
you want all books all your references
for N and M you pick his hole you put
something through now traditionally you
used a darning needle but as a way if
these these holes are so big in the
demonstration verge I'm going to
emphasize this is a digital process by
using my finger and you you shake the
cards and the right ones fall out this
is the retrieval technology of the 1950s
so this is what this is what we got
replaced now as I said because of things
like Sputnik there was a boom time for
retrieval in the 50s and 60s more people
attended sagir special interest group on
information retrieval conferences in the
early sixties or the predecessor
conferences actually then attended them
a couple of years ago it's really
remarkable the first experiments were
systems that used indexing because
things were being keyed in and they were
paying
fool to do what happened in the sixties
thing when we got into the experimental
schoolboy stage was people started doing
experiments on free text retrieval most
particularly Gerry Salton who died
recently unfortunately of cancer a few
weeks ago Gerry was the first person to
try to do large-scale experiments to say
yes free text indexing can be compared
and really work Gerry worked a lot with
a man named Cyril clever and Cyril
clever Dan was the inventor of the
recall and precision measures for the
first time we had an attempt to make
this part of computer science an
experimental science in which people
would run experiments this is not
typical in computer science you know
people do not do evaluated experiments
when I wrote uucp we didn't say oh well
now let's take 20 MIT undergraduates and
tell 10 of them to get a message to
brown with uucp and 10 of them to try
Amtrak or greyhound and see which ones
get there first
we just sort of write it and put it out
and say here well Jerry and Cyril had
the idea that no information retrieval
was going to be evaluated experiments
because there was this history of there
is a lot of stuff out there and we need
an effective way to find it there had
been a a long tradition of well the way
to do this is with standardized
nomenclature and whatnot but nobody knew
whether they would really work and so
there were a lot of experiments were
done the test collections in fact that
Gerry and Cyril prepared in the 1960s
were basically still in use until about
1992 as the standard retrieval
techniques now this stuff was all basic
keyword retrieval as this work was going
on some new techniques that were also
sort of statistical went on like
relevance feedback the idea that well
we'll find one relevant document and
we'll use that as a search term to
search a set of search terms to retrieve
more relevant documents but all of this
was again statistical now at the same
time I said there's this other thread
the other thread is intellectual
analysis and in the AI contact in the in
the IR context that was AI that was
artificial intelligence and what we had
was that people like Terry Winograd and
Daniel
began looking at programs that would do
linguistic analysis of queries and
perhaps of documents and attempt to
match them an attempt to retrieve
answers on that basis now these two
groups didn't get along very well the AI
people were in the computer science
tradition of we're gonna build something
that will make enough examples to fill
the back of a thesis and that's it and
the IR people were down this trend of
we're gonna run the same 1,400 document
X collection over and over again until
the experimenters have memorized all the
articles on aeronautics and while this
was going on the 2d but the tension is
still there the tension fortunately is
only at the research level because at
this point we're still in the schoolboy
phase and not that much is actually
getting done now then we get into the
1970s in the 1970s we're now in we're
now an adult the field is now you know
in the 20s and what's happening and the
main thing that's happening is computer
typesetting and word processing
you know I appreciated Ted Nelson's
video tape of real cut and paste I
remember that I haven't seen anybody do
that you know for 20 years once we had
computer typesetting and I hadn't
realized you know that Bush woodwork of
it one of the other things I learned
from Andy's talk was that Bush had
worked on typesetting and they had
worked on management theory so that he
was not only the progenitor of
information retrieval but he was also
sort of the antecedent of monotype and
Linotype model of the modern typesetting
machines and of Dilbert but we have we
now have because of computer typesetting
and word processing we had large volumes
of material in free text we also had
online time sharing all of the
experiments Jerry salton did in the 60s
were done in a batch world you wrote
down your queries he sent them into his
system he got it back late and there was
a whole lot of talk about selective
dissemination of information people
would write down lists of queries and
leave them in the background to be run
and this all was blown away when
time-sharing came in all of a sudden you
could put up these real systems you also
had some early examples of real
cooperation
oclc for example this was an
organization now called the was
originally called the Ohio college
library center that being an
insufficiently expansive name it is now
the online computer library center about
OCLC was founded to distribute catalog
carts to libraries and there was a
cooperative effort if a library got a
book which hadn't been cataloged in the
file they would catalog it and enter it
in the file and other people would then
retrieve that record and if you entered
a record you got the next ten records
free or something as an incentive to do
that these were all very limited search
systems but they were very popular a lot
of promises were made why we look at the
next slide
people people believe that you know
there was going to be a change in
libraries last chance for everything
goes on microfilm and now if we could
look at the top half of the next slide
please
there were a lot of there are earlier
statements about microfilm that will
remind you of some of the statements
that have been made over the years by
the more extreme proponents of
artificial intelligence and hypertext in
which people say that microfilm
microphotography is one of the most
important developments in the
transmission of the printed word since
Gutenberg and so what I have to say from
this is that is that hypertext did not
only not invent text as they would have
you believe they didn't even invent hype
so what happened in the 70s in the
research arena well again we still got
this tension we still have the people
doing statistical processing and now in
fact they get a new weapon
Keitha and Rosberg and shows up with
probabilistic information retrieval and
introduces even more statistics to an
area mean I should confess that I'm not
terribly sympathetic to things like
statistics now I was taught as a chemist
that statistics are what people do when
they can't get their apparatus and good
enough adjustment to get convincing
answers
but we we went on and the AI people
we're getting into trouble now they had
made lots of promises about what they
were going to do with machine
translation and computational
linguistics and to get away from these
they had started making promises about
art about speech recognition and the
thing they did that got into information
retrieval was they invented expert
systems now the easiest way to think
about expert systems in the late 70s and
early 80s is that they occupied the same
buzzword niche that intelligent agents
do today and people wrote for example
the 1980s are very probably going to be
the error of the expert system by the
end of the decade it is possible that
each of us will telephone an expert
system whenever we need to obtain advice
and information on a range of technical
legal or medical topics in fact when I
went out to get quotes like that for
some talk a few years ago it was
shooting fish in a barrel they were all
over the place people have wildly
different views about the importance of
this you know my name is les it's a very
rare name and it's not an English word
or a word in any other language that I
know when I do a search on leskanic
database if I don't find myself that's
because I found my brother and my second
cousin that's it
stew card is in the room I suspect stew
card does not feel the same way about
dumb searching of ordinary strings there
was a problem though that none of the AI
systems really seemed to generalize very
well
Roger shank was perhaps the best
proponent of AI systems in the 70s that
were going to introduce higher level
language processing and their idea was
that every document could be mapped into
standard frameworks for example there's
a very large number of medical articles
that boiled down to we have a Bachelor
rats they're all suffering from
such-and-such a disease we gave them
such-and-such and some of them got
better and some of them died this is how
many in each category and shanks group
would try to construct such schemas for
many areas and then they try to fill
them out they produced a lot of argument
about whether this was for real or not
there were other systems like bill woods
or lunar system or stan patrick's
transformational question answer that
were evaluated but they tended not to do
off ordinary text so we weren't getting
very far on this but we still had this
tension
people said now all you need is
statistics and now intellectual analysis
will help but everyone was going away
from manual indexing also but we can't
afford to do manual indexing so if we're
gonna do intellectual analysis it's
going to have to be done by machines and
we've got to get machines that are smart
enough to do that so now we get on to
the 1980s and a couple of things go on
in the 1980s we have a steady increase
in word processing to the extent that it
becomes impossible to buy hot led
typesetting machines and they only exist
as sort of craft print craft devices and
the price of disk space goes down so
everybody starts to think of ah these
are going to be the new alternatives
let's there there's a little date on the
next few slots ok the next slide please
there's pigment have any data this is a
Burke Breathitt outlet out land cartoon
in which one of the characters comes
over and says you know could I borrow
oh no he said we're in the brink of a
gleaming digital upheaval 500 cable
channels so many sitcoms so little time
TVs telephones computers merged in one
our lives that wash with instant visual
input and well what do you want well
actually wanted to curl up with your
copy of Winnie the Pooh and you can see
in the last frame that the guy is here
staring at a compact disc and that's
what what well we'll go on to the next
one they got next next slide the next
slide is why the libraries are starting
to chase this so hard why there's a
business here this is what university
library budgets look like your typical
University spends 3 to 4 percent on its
library unless it's the place up the
river that you all are afraid of which
spends about 6 or 7 percent on its
library actually there was a nasty
comment about Harvard made or maybe
nasty one back all right
I'm talking about the seven ages of man
in Shakespeare everybody who knows which
play it comes from raise your hand
got you as you the answer is as you like
it but it reminds me of the story about
the time the bus fare in Cambridge went
from 50 cents to 60 cents and some kid
gets on and he pays the old fare and
walks past without realizing a bus
driver calls out and says hey you are
you from MIT and you can't reader from
Harvard and you can't count anyway most
universities three to four percent on
the library and it's not going up why is
the library budget go about a third of
it goes for purchases about half of it
goes for salaries the rest goes for
other this is not quite fair most
universities don't monetize space about
another third would have to be added if
the library were charged the fair rental
value of the buildings its cluttering up
of what spent on buying a book where
does that go the right-hand column is
the breakdown of the prices of books
retail markup is like 40% distributor
gets 15% printer gets 15% publishing
office gets 20% author gets 10% what
that means is if you say suppose we blew
away this system suppose you know what
Ted Nelson wants happen we were getting
stuff directly from the author to the
reader and we didn't have to bother with
paying for the printer or paying for the
library and put it on the shelf you know
relatively little that money is needed
so there's a lot of potential economic
gain in this system if we can do it can
we do it next slide is the price of disk
space over time and this is a chart of
how much Nick spray you see it's going
down very nicely and now I'll tell you
what the people in the back can see
which is it's a log scale between 1971
and now we've had a hundred thousand
fold decrease in the price of disk space
so that's why these things are becoming
possible next slide is as a result the
increase in the number of databases but
an interesting thing that top green is
the number of online commercial
databases the red line near the bottom
that's going up much faster is cd-rom
and then the mag tape is the blue line
that's actually going down so
we're seeing is a switch to cd-roms
which were becoming increasingly popular
cd-rom is one of the big inventions of
the 80s
let's go on let me well let me just talk
for a minute about the 80s
okay by the 80s we're up to 40 the 40
year mark right so the system is the
world is now getting mature and what
that means is yes
these systems are commercially available
lots of people have personal talents on
dialogue and
CompuServe and they're looking things up
and people are actually getting used to
OPEX ordinary people walk into libraries
now and they get met with computer
terminals not with card catalogues some
of the right nasty articles for The New
Yorker magazine and make trouble for us
but basically most people are pretty
happy
what is annoying people is that the
research community has been cranking
along all these years right and they've
invented probabilistic retrieval and
relevance wee-bey and none of its in use
all these commercial services are doing
dom free tech searching they don't think
they need either intellectual analysis
or even good statistical analysis the AI
community meanwhile is down on this
expert system in knowledge
representation language stuff that
imagines translations into unbelievably
sophisticated and complicated languages
I mean flying inbound got the Turing
Award last year I think he should have
gotten a special award from the
Department of Commerce for sending the
Japanese down the fifth-generation
rattle and the enthusiasm I mean the
early part of the 80s this stuff was
riding high but the middle of the 80s we
got what is called AI winter and we have
now gone into a world in which instead
of people believing that it was possible
and I should say by the idea that you
can take natural language descriptions
of subjects and turn them into a single
artificial symbolism predates artificial
intelligence there's probably one other
person in the room who remembers the
name JJ Farah Dane put your hand up
where dick where's dick Marcus you must
know Feridun he's the only way Farah
Dane was this British information
retrieval guy who came up with this
amazing
ix operator language with special
symbols for each operator you know and
he believed that if he encoded something
in this language you get a hundred
percent precision and recall everything
would be perfect well
the same thing as translating into
psychosom languidly most people now are
sort of almost back there there was a
famous linguist named Benjamin Lee Whorf
Worf had a theory that in fact language
constrains faut what you will think
depends on the language were used to
express and many of us are going back to
believe things like that okay so now
we're made it through the 80s things are
going fine basically the intellectual
analysis people are in full retreat the
statistical people are riding high their
stuff all the systems that are running
or dumb and we get into the 1990s and
the world is now you know in the late
40s and it's time for the midlife crisis
what is happening well what happens is
the Internet even one year ago there
were people at Bell core saying to me
only 15% of the computers in people's
homes even have modems who cares about
the internet nobody says that anymore
I've now see I now see charts suggesting
that by 2003 the entire population of
the world will be on the net now what is
remarkable is that everybody is
providing it and everybody is
classifying it themselves it's the you
know it's the Revenge of the bush people
over the we were people the Weaver
people have been winning for 40 years
they've almost won and now all of a
sudden the bush people make a comeback
and there's all these people you know
organizing their own stuff now
admittedly there is a lot of problem
with quality on this you know there when
I was I used to be taught as an example
of probability the statement that if you
took a million monkeys and sat them in a
million typewriters it gave them long
enough they write all the works of
Shakespeare the internet has proven that
this is not true there is
[Applause]
sorry there is you know there's this
vast amount in that the question is how
do you sort through this I mean the
Lycos people now think there are ten
million pages on the net or more you
know everybody now thinks you're you
know in the 80s I first met with the
expectation that everyone is supposed to
have a fax machine and now you meet with
the expectation everyone is supposed to
have a home page what are the world's
hard disk industry we'll ship over a
terabyte of discs this year two
megabytes for every person in the world
I can remember not too long ago when the
people at Bell Labs not a stingy
institution we're bugging me to keep my
disk space below 200 kilobytes the next
thing I will talk about is well what are
we going to do to get some of the
quality valued information into the
libraries and one of the answers is
scanning one of the big things that
happened in the 80s was the 1990s is the
rise of scanning so the next slide shows
an example I figure I have to sooner or
later get to my own research this is a
sample of the core information retrieval
system which we built at Cornell this is
based on scanned chemical journals the
this page is an image of a real page
this is also an image you're looking at
a picture of the page you know we they
say somebody keyed the page in in
Columbus Ohio took the computer
typesetting tape printed it on paper I
took the paper fed it back in through a
scanning machine we get that you may say
that stuff the next slide is the
alternative it is an ascii thing in
which in this case it's a different
Belcore retrieval system but in this
case this stuff is regenerated from
asking we did some experiments or
actually we as Dennis Egan who's sitting
in the back somewhere people can read
both of these about equally quickly so
they both work and they both work if you
have to search for something a lot
better than paper so you now see a lot
of things coming out in image form a lot
of libraries doing things some more
examples of how you get things in the
next the next slide shows another
turn ative how you might get things into
the digital library Mozart writing the
digital version of Symphony number 38
this this is not what you do let's see
what's the next put up the next slide
the next slide is an example people
wanted I was having some people who
wanted to digitize Charles Sanders purse
so he wrote a hundred thousand pages of
manuscript such as that at the bottom
and you could scan it in and the
scholars could read it I should say the
sample here is the page when he was
applying for money to the Carnegie
Foundation to publish his works in 1900
they turned him down
in 1992 about the people who wanted to
scan all his manuscripts applied to the
Carnegie Foundation for money and they
got turned down again so scholars never
learned let's skip the next slide go on
to the one after that which is an
example once you get into images you can
do lots of other things this is a
British Library 1771 map of New England
the black is the original map the red is
an overlay of where the boundaries
really are assuming that the Geological
Survey today knows what it's doing
and if you look at this you'll see that
the latitude is reasonably good but the
longitude is somewhat mucked up which is
what you'd expect the next slide is
another scanned map and this slide is
one of the reasons why you're not seeing
these you know from some I'm sorry they
rotate it 90 degrees please right this
is Manhattan Island in 1775 and the
reason that I'm not really doing this on
a spark book the image from which this
comes is 50 megabytes and it takes a
little bit long to put up and the view
graph goes up very quickly simply as a
matter of attractiveness we'll put up
the next slide which is another map Lord
Jeffrey Amherst map of New York in 1770
the next slide is to move on to still
other medium and there's lots of talk
about other media I like to listen to
the radio so I've got this system where
I've got a radio plugged into my
workstation permanently tuned to the
public radio station renew your
and every day it digitizes all things
considered in morning edition and I can
listen to them at my convenience later
and I can actually listen to them faster
than normal
I can also clip out interesting things
and save them and I can do things like
segment by looking for silences the top
bit is that I also like to listen to the
BBC well you know they don't really
broadcast a strong enough signal so a
colleague in London has a radio plugged
into her workstation and it's tuned to
Breezy BC Radio 4 if you ever wonder why
the response on the net isn't even good
at 4:30 a.m. it's because there are
people like me dragging over the BBC
from London so they can listen to it
when they get to work late let's see
other things Bush talked about OCR the
next slide is some random attempt to
evaluate OCR and the top is a newspaper
story which would be perfectly readable
to you if you could see it it got 80
percent of the words write better
printing you get 90 percent but if
you're counting by words this we still
don't have that we need to get there the
next slide is another example of why you
would like to have images and the
problem
Katzie 83 bytes that little frame-maker
sketch was a thousand bytes in
framemaker
the picture on the right is 12,000 bytes
so a picture is worth a thousand words
but it costs it I said the price of disk
space had gone down about a factor of a
hundred thousand the problem is the
difference between video and ASCII is
about fifty thousand so nearly all of
the progress has been given back what
does that mean in the 1960s and early
70s all sorts of scholars had keypunch
one thing they had their copy of
Paradise Lost or something that they had
keyed in that they were doing research
on and right now it's the same way I
mean people who have their forty-five
seconds of digital video that they're
experimenting with so all right based on
past history another five to ten years
we're gonna have really large digital
collections which we will videotape
what is happening in with that well
we're search interesting thing with
research there is suddenly a text
retrieval industry all of a sudden
watches let me let me back off I want to
talk a little bit about the libraries
again in their getting all this stuff
and next slide please
here's another quote for the futures you
know libraries for books will have
ceased to exist to be true in nineteen
eighty four predicted in 1964 no that's
not you know it didn't happen today it's
another story why what are the relative
cost scanning a book well let's put up
the next slide please
scanning a book costs about thirty
dollars little between thirty and forty
and another ten dollars to pay for the
disk drive to hold it to build a space
to put it on the shelf
Cornell twenty dollars for book in the
newest book stack they've built Berkeley
is building a stack at thirty dollars
per book the top building there the
British Library in London will come in
at seventy five dollars per book and the
French National Library is a hundred
dollars per space for a book on this
shelf so the libraries are now in a
situation where within a few years it
will be cheaper for them to scan and not
put up the space to put the book and
since many of them are under strong
pressure not to put up anymore buildings
for other reasons you're going to see an
awful lot more of conversion it's
already economical if any libraries
could get together but they can't do it
like let's see we also have a text
retrieval industry next slide is the
online search industry we're a couple of
billion dollars a year now among the
different vendors in which LexisNexis is
biggest in dialog is next the next slide
is the software sales to support that
industry this is from nineteen ninety to
ninety six the rate of growth in selling
programs like personal librarian and
diner text and things like that so this
is a thriving business now and by God
all of the research technologies that
have been ignored for so long are now in
use bruce Crofts Center for intelligent
information retrieval which has
developed
a lot of intelligent text processing
algorithms provided the software for the
Thomas system it's the Library of
Congress
Jerry Sultan's software was used to make
a cd-rom encyclopedia the Waze system
has relevance feedback in it so we have
an active industry and by God is finally
using the research results politically
we have a big thing vice president
Gore's people probably know decided that
since his father had started the
interstate highway bill through Congress
he would do the internet in the national
information infrastructure as the
analogous thing and he constantly talks
about his school child in his hometown
of Carthage Tennessee being able to turn
on our computer and plug into the
Library of Congress and so the feds have
started a major digital library program
do me a favor skip the next two slides
and put up the one after that the black
spots here are the federally DLI groups
at Stanford Santa Barbara Berkley
Michigan of some other projects are in
green for example the JSTOR project in
Michigan is the Mellon Foundation's
attempt to see whether it really is true
that libraries can scan as a replacement
for shelf space and what Mellon is doing
is paying to scan ten major economics
and history journals back to the
beginning of time of their time and
seeing whether these libraries can use
these instead we also got a return to
evaluation I said that for thirty years
everybody had been using the same
collections for evaluation and Donnell
Hartmann started running something
called the trek conference in which
people sent in hundreds of queries were
run against a gigabyte of text and you
suddenly got some realistic numbers and
what we learned not surprisingly was
that there is still enormous scatter in
the performance of these systems the
reason we can't agree on what a good
system is is that it depends very much
on the query and the user you could do
enormous ly better with best hindsight
if you could say for each query on this
query we'll use that search system the
other query will use the other search
system we don't know how to do that yet
but there's there's clearly gains to be
made so as I say the midlife crisis is
all of a sudden this is succeeding but
it's succeeding
manual content analysis rather than just
the statistical retrieval they're
actually both working together sort of
the bush disciples of me to come back
all right so what happens next the next
decade is the 2000s ir is going to be
fifty five to sixty five so this is
fulfillment you know right we should be
slaying away the money for our
retirement and our problem is going to
be how are we going to do the image we
couldn't get all these images video
it's bad enough indexing the text at
least we have free text retrieval what
are we going to do with all the images
of the video you've got to be we've got
to have manual analysis for that at the
moment I don't know how we do it that's
going to be the big issue but it's going
to have to rely on people doing it at
the moment and that's going to require
us to learn how to manage manual
indexing after many years in which
librarians were sort of viewed as you
know well why brands are sort of the
equivalent of quill pen makers in the
typesetting era suddenly we need these
people we need people know how to
organize information and make use of it
uh okay but I think we can get through
that
finally 2010 this is I've labeled it
retirement on my viewgraph
put back that put back the original view
graphic please Shakespeare had it his
senility I prefer to be more optimistic
at this point I think that basically the
conversion job has been done that by
thirty years in a dwell by this time we
will have had enough of the scanning and
enough of the keying available and we
will have a market in which people can
buy this stuff that we will basically
have the material we need online we will
need how to know how to find it but we
will have it there and sort of we can
all go off to study biotech or something
the the printed books remain sort of in
warehouses somewhere the library
buildings on campuses has been turned
over to more bureaucrats and
administrators and you know something
else now what what might go wrong with
this I'm very optimistic but
what are the problems going to be one of
them is internationalism we're doing
just fine now on the internet on the
assumption that everybody in the world
speaks English at some point that's
going to break that and it's going to be
political as well as technical there's
going to need to be more more new kinds
of research I am a little worried that
ten years from now there will be library
departments giving PhDs and arcane
details of probabilistic indexing
carrying out the arguments that keith
van Ryberg and had with jerry Salton in
the 1970s you know we've got to get on
to some of these things there will be a
few of us old fogies who even remember
that we were promised automatic language
parsing in question-answering or still
waiting for it more seriously I'm
worried about some of the social effects
CB radio anybody remember CB radio right
you know lots of trash how do we keep
the internet from being overwhelmed with
that stuff how do we get a role for the
people who will sort out what is
reasonable and what is not and let us
find that stuff that is going to require
some form of charging Bob Kahn already
said we need to go to service charges we
need some leadership and how to do this
right my problem is that it was hard to
look to economics for leadership even
the Economist magazine once said that an
economist was somebody who was good with
numbers but lacks the personal charisma
to be an accountant and there is a
problem of where do we get the
leadership to build a system such as the
one that Ted Nelson has envisioned where
you know people actually do get paid it
works at the moment the copyright law is
a real problem somebody you know
somebody made some comment about what we
needed more legal stuff I mean I have
been going to computer conferences since
1969 so I remember the days before there
were lawyers in computing
I never heard at one of those
conferences anybody suggest and we had a
problem in computing because there
weren't enough lawyers paying attention
to it there is a story that ok oh and
dr. IBM did prepare a cd-rom to
commemorate the 50th anniversary of the
Columbus voyage to America there is a
story that they paid over a million
dollars to clear the rights for the
material used on that CD
that's okay but only 10,000 of it was
paid to the rights holders all the West
went into the administrative costs you
know we have to get somewhere there is a
real possibility that the world of the
future is everything published after
about 1990 is available because the
publishers have it and they're making it
available everything before 1920 which
is out of copyright is available and
everything in between is falling into a
black hole in which every once in a
while someone tries hard to find the to
find the people who have control and get
get the data finally as I allege in an
earlier question I'm worried about
political problems there are
technologies which looked as if they
were going to be successful and have
been stopped by political or legal
liability issues there's a nuclear power
childhood vaccination we need to try to
design our worlds where that doesn't
happen to us all right but I don't want
to end on unhappy note you know it is
possible that we will all you know be
drowned in information blot or something
but I think that it will actually work I
think given the rates of progress Bush's
dream will be achieved in one lifetime
in the lifetime of this profession
now Bush actually talked about the
Oregon information organization it said
there will be a new profession there
will be Trailblazers people who make
trails on request now part of the
problem is that today people think of
librarians is someone who alphabetizes
books or puts them on shelf the function
that is known in a library is marking
Park you label the book and stuff it on
the shelf
we need to get sort of a higher status
for this whether it's called information
Trailblazer I'm not as good as some
people is making up new words for things
I'm optimistic about that once upon a
time accountants had to be good Neurath
macaca then computers came along and
made skill in doing arithmetic totally
irrelevant to the real world did that
mean that accountants became
uninteresting minimum-wage people no
accountants took over all the major
corporations you know being
counters now run the world so if
computers go in there and say right
alphabetizing is no longer interesting
what happens to librarians and I hope
that your information becomes more
valuable somebody earlier talked about
information as a see all right the
purpose of librarians and trailblaze or
whatever the purpose of those people in
the future is now going to be to
navigate it is not going to be to
provide the water that's it
thank you great
let's have some questions for Michael no
no but then you won't be recorded Ted
please how do you see the copyright
issue as resolving first of all the
question was by Ted Nelson the I I don't
I would hope frankly that some payment
scheme is adopted my personal guess is
that it will be a much simpler scheme
than yours when I talk to the journal
publishers and say how do you want to
charge for your stuff online
they don't say a hundredth of a cent a
byte or hundreds of a cent a minute
they say twenty-five dollars a year
because that's what they're used to when
I talk to a book publisher and say what
do you want to charge for online access
$50 a person so my hope is that there
will be larger and bigger units charged
so that I don't get into the huge
overhead of two cents here and three
cents there you think that's a simpler
system yeah I do you know what I would
really like I'd really like the German
solution the tax on blank tape you know
the Germans do this they want to deal
with over-the-air taping and they put a
tax on blank tape and give the money to
the German society of composers and I
wish some mechanism like that would work
I've never understood why in the u.s.
political context a tax on blank tape
which is all made in the Far East for
the benefit of recording artists who are
all America
doesn't go through Congress but he never
does anyway Michael you said they're
only about the terabyte Raj really only
a terabyte of sales of disk I don't know
where you got them I'm sorry I'm sorry
to the it's the 10 to the 15th I'm sorry
yeah it's a petabyte yeah at least a
petabyte is yes last year 50 million
pieces were sold even if each of them
had only hundred megabytes it would be
more than a petabyte will be at least
five petabytes it is probably more like
2030 the number that I got came from Jim
Gray giving a talk at vldb last fall
changing every day I mean that's that
may be the answer that we only bought
one gigabyte this this year we're buying
nine gigabyte discs for the same price
the second issue I think is more
interesting you said OCR doesn't work
one company care has a fifteen million
dollars a year product business yes
obviously a lot of people are buying it
and using it so none of the technologies
that you talked about and we are all
working on will ever be perfect
including information retrieval the
precision and recall is still pretty
lousy yes and it will never get better
than that much better that would be
perfect
yes the question is what went how do you
define what works and what does not work
when my friends stopped sending things
to be key punched in the Philippines
because OCR is good enough that they
don't need to do that anymore and lots
of people are still doing it I gather to
tell you a really horrible story
admittedly from a few years ago a friend
of mine runs the this is a long time in
this industry
OCR isn't changing that much well a
friend of mine was involved in having
the of the publication's of the AI
double-a put into one of the online
services she not only talked to the
online service about do you want the
pages to OCR they offer them the
typesetting tapes the service said nah
we'll send it to Korea
you know we got lots of people we can
hire overseas to keystroke we can't even
find people to decode your typesetting
format let alone to patch up the OCR so
I still see too much stuff being sent
out for keen definition and most people
routinely use scanners for use of
information rather than sending it out
but to be keep on people use OCR rather
than the same way speech recognition I
will recognize is really practical when
the business of typing from dictation
disappears so the issue is whether when
you're type with the right word
processor you make mistakes also yes and
you learn to live with it you fix it
when you make a mistake so the issue is
when you make a mistake with a voice
input you'll make mistakes there's no
such thing and it'll never be perfect
but handle input and voice input
including keyboard input for word
processing will never be perfect I agree
it's not perfect librarians have a funny
attitude towards this they read too many
books on total quality maintenance long
before there were any such courses a
friend of mine you know made the mistake
of saying in public that the keystroking
in the British Library catalogue had
introduced 50,000 lost books by errors
and the press marks he got fired for it
I'm more a more interesting story many
people have thought of the idea of let's
scan something OCR it and because the
OCR isn't perfect we'll use the OCR only
for searching behind the scenes and will
display the scanned image this is the
way the ELLs of your tula project works
I first heard this idea from 20 years
ago at the National Agricultural library
and I said well what happened to that
project answer they started it but they
had the OCR it seemed ridiculous to have
this and not send it out to the people
who were buying this the scan disks but
it wasn't accurate it was embarrassing
to send it out this way so they started
trying to correct it then they couldn't
afford to put out the product so the
whole thing's gone and I said you
couldn't argue
went out and just distribute knowing
inaccurate stuff but saying for its
purpose it's good enough no that's not
our worldview we want to be proud of
what we're doing don't forget it adobe
selling a product just like the one you
mentioned you can buy it in the market
yes for a couple of hundred dollars
right now I mean okay Samuel Epstein
with Sense Media Net and one of the
things that you mentioned was that I
guess by the year 2000 or some date like
that that all the information that we
need will be digitized and up on the net
ready to be retrieved one of my concerns
and I started to see it now with a lot
of the smaller kids that we do some work
with is that the idea that well anything
that we need to find we can find by you
know going into info seeker like us and
doing it regarding the parochialism of
data and the fact that you know even
even in a few years or 20 years that
there's gonna be a lot of stuff that is
not on the net and stuff that even never
will be on the net whether it's coming
out of a rain forest or whoever how do
we as designers of these systems impart
to our users that this is not the end to
all ends of information retrieval and as
seductive as it sounds the reality is
sometimes you gotta go crawl around a
jungle I know and I the unfortunate
answer I think is if you go to Western
European libraries there are many
manuscripts in them that have never been
printed the average manuscript that
survives in an old library has not been
transcribed to printing in 500 years so
what's happened to this stuff since no
ordinary person ever finds it a few
devoted scholars shrinking with
university budgets every year devote
their lives to crawling through this so
if somebody says does there happen to be
any estimate of the cost of having a
horse shot in Germany in 1300 one of
them pipes up and says yeah I saw that
20 years ago it's in a library and
Dresden or something the same thing I am
afraid is going to happen to the data
that is not easily available in
electronic form and this is unfortunate
and I don't really know what to do about
it because I'm afraid that the cost of
converting the entire past is too high
enough will be converted to serve most
people most of the time and then we're
gonna be stuck and I don't know how to
get around that
just as a follow up do you see possibly
you know now we're starting to see
advertisements for professional paid
netsurfers to go out there and search
the web do you see in the future
potential for a career as a professional
Oh analog information surfer yeah I I I
think there will be my problem is that I
think that the career for somebody who
wants to dig around in the non
electronic stuff will turn out to be a
few spot you know say a few specialists
as with the people who deal with
manuscripts I mean there's this whole
profession of archivist and you know you
cannot get a job in it so I just don't
know I wish I wish people would be more
interested in diversity in getting more
kinds of information thanks John Smith
University of North Carolina um like to
ask you two related questions if I could
first a factual question and then a kind
of an opinion question your projection
about this or your vision is kind of
based on this in part on this
amortization of cost for storing and
providing access to books and the sort
of declining curve of cost for disk
space but what you didn't mention is
what is the cost trend for moving bits
around the internet is that going up
going down are we seeing any kind of
logarithmic decrease in that because it
seems to me that this vision really is
predicated on on lowering lore and lower
cost of that and the second question is
kind of a follow-on to that and that is
I think a lot of us think that Internet
is a kind of god-given right but it
expands in use I'm really worried about
how it's going to be financed to bring
it up to that level of service and so I
wonder if what kind of economic model
you see in the future that would make
the internet universally accessible it's
irresistible bob is the next person at
the microphone and he can answer both of
these questions better than I can know
the reality is costs of transmission are
going way down I mean for example when
you were growing up long distance calls
cost a lot more than low
we'll call today most large purchases of
long-distance service pay irrespective
of distance you know where l.l.bean will
pay something like six cents a minute
flat rate anywhere in the United States
so these costs are coming down and all
the costs are coming down you have given
me the option Ted gave out this paper
and one of the things he says in this
1965 paper is the costs are now down
considerably a small computer with mass
memory and video type display now cost
thirty-seven thousand dollars
several people could use it around the
clock all of these costs are are
crashing now how does how do we
advertise how do we arrange that people
like me who are perhaps using vast
quantities of Internet service for
frivolous purposes get charged more than
people who are you know only using a
little I don't know how that will play
out my gut feeling is that the bandwidth
regulation model we have now which is
that Belcore pays more because it has a
t1 length and people who have a 9600
baud link is not entirely unreasonable
so I'm sort of peak bandwidth limitation
pricing but I don't you know that the
economists are gonna have to sort that
one out Bob Kahn Michael I'd like to get
you to speculate about retirement in
2010 in particular given that this is a
birth to retirement process the
presumption I make is that you think
that the information retrieval problem
will have been solved by then I'm afraid
that that may turn out to be more hype
than it is reality in that people's
expectations of what the information
retrieval capabilities will be will be
far greater than the reality so can you
give us some sense of the scope of our
information retrieval capabilities at
retirement what I believe will have
happened is that there will be vast
numbers of people for reasons I probably
won't understand who have put together
enough trails on enough subjects that
when I sit down and I say
I want to find a photograph of Bob Kahn
there will be a way to do it now I don't
understand all this there are some
subjects on the net you know if I want
to know the names assigned to the
locomotives of any class of British
Railways I assure you I can post that
question and 30 people will fall over
themselves to show off that they can
answer it if I were to say what fraction
of current computer programs are written
in Pascal
I am also quite confident I would not
receive a single competent answer
although I would receive many idiotic
opinions I don't know how to arrange
that for every subject there will be
some bibliography equivalent but I
believe that is what it will be what I'm
saying is the bush people are eventually
going to win over the Weaver people
we're not going to be able to do the
image and sound and video analysis I
know Raj you know I know there's a nice
demo at CMU of how we're going to solve
all these problems but I'm not convinced
whereas I am amazed by the number of
people on the web willing to spend their
time collecting every locomotive picture
every picture of a pet rabbit and making
lists of them someone objects to the pet
rabbits I okay great great way to finish
[Applause]
okay we're going to go for half an hour
max we're going to take some local
questions and then we're going to take
some questions via the mbone all right
who will be first okay
general or to any one particular perhaps
both but I think I'll direct the
question first to Robert come my name is
Ricky Goldman Siegel and I deal a lot
with video annotation tools I was
concerned about one of the things you
talked about which was this notion of
malleable content and I guess what
worries me and what I think about it's
not is that what happens when the
content that we have let's say the video
images are images of people in our own
research that we've taken in our own
research of children and adults doing
all kinds of things now we have ethical
approval to use those we might even have
ethical approval to use them on the
Internet
but what happens when someone else uses
that and takes it out of context it's
not just a matter of authorship because
let's say I'm the author I'm the
research okay I have the authorship it's
not just an issue of property rights
it's an issue of ethics and no one in
the panel today no one in any of the
span of the speaker's day address the
issue of the ethics of malleable content
so could you talk about that please I
mean malleable content is not exactly a
household word in most quarters and even
today in the world of what I would call
hard copyright I don't mean hardcore
copyright I just mean hard copy right
there are moral rights that do attach to
them
you might think that after copyright
runs out you can do anything you want
but under the Berne Convention there are
still moral rights retained by authors
so for example if you were to try and do
syncopated whoever and the state of that
musician did not want you to do that
because they thought it it impinge upon
the moral rights of the musical works
writer they could prevent you from doing
that legally and some other kinds of
constraints occur in in other related
area so moral rights even pertain when
you have hard copyright where you think
it's now in the public domain but it was
originally protected my sense of what's
needed to happen is that people need to
be able to state what it is they're
willing to have happen to material that
they have rights in and if somebody
really does not want somebody else to
manipulate material that they have
rights in that is their prerogative and
therefore it is all the trappings of the
law that would normally pertain in
whatever part of the world that you're
in would apply ought to apply to that on
the other hand I can see many people
providing material where they say you
can make changes you know for example
suppose that I had created a film called
Gone with the Wind pick your favorite
but I put it out into the world of
cyberspace in a form where the storyline
was out there motions of the characters
with was out there and the only thing
that was not really fixed was the actual
choice of characters or the location but
all the rest of it was sort of pinned
down in the storyline and let's say Mike
my garland was fixed the storyline can't
change that but you can change the party
so you could watch Gone with the Wind
starring you as Scarlett for example and
that might be your like that would be
okay with me okay but maybe I put out
another one where I sort of had the
start of a good story and it was really
more like interactive fiction and you
could change the storyline by virtue of
actions that you took and that was okay
with me because you aren't
changing the core that is manipulating
the changes of the storyline and that
was what I put out there there may be
somebody else who says well I'm gonna
put out a blank slate and you can put
anything you want on there and they
consider that a work although somebody
else might not so I see a whole range of
possibilities I just would like to make
it possible that we can deal with
derivative works out there or additions
to works here's another case in point
nobody can stop you today from doing a
visual overlay on a wall so if you are
doing a simultaneous showing of a and B
two different audio-visual works then
what you see is the composite of those
two and somebody may object for legal
reasons that you're affecting their
original but you're actually not
changing it directly you're just
changing the visual experience that
somebody has so I could easily see
somebody giving you a template that if
somebody else created one that would do
a projection that would overlay on it in
fact that might be okay too
I just like to once again explain how
the trans copyright seems to some people
to solve this issue what what you see
what's been at the end of the trail here
has been the problem that all copyright
owners have under this Berne Convention
of of being able to stop you from taking
things out of context and meanwhile
people are quote downloading things on
the network and inventing for themselves
all sorts of schemes on there in their
minds that make it reasonable and
correct and with with total ignorance of
the law basically so that the the trans
copyright proposal is essentially that
anyone can reuse this arbitrarily in a
new context pre-pre permission for that
new context with the understanding that
all the pieces will be bought from the
originator now what about altering the
bytes there that's where it gets into
trouble so the the only way the trans
copyright thing works is if the bytes
are always obtained from the originator
so what you want somebody if you want it
to be stretched and morphed or something
like that what the map then contains is
the directions for how to stretch and
morph these things once you download
them and that gives the the desired
result so malleability is
then that is possible within that
framework on a strict basis the reason
that some people want to talk about the
moral issue and others of us want to
talk about the legalistic issue is that
moral isms can blow away with the wind
whereas if you can set down some
guidelines that can be implemented as a
as a workable solution that people can
live with that could that could have a
long-term effect I can I can offer an
alternative I could offer an alternative
the alternative point of view to
suggesting that everybody the trends
copyright should be mandated basically
should be a flag that you turn on or
turn off I is to say to make two
observations first of all you to observe
that a system which tries to constrain
how people behave doesn't fly so if you
for example make a documentation which
requires everybody to to write in a
given word processor it doesn't work if
you try to make a system which which
changes the way the relationships that
people have which forces into some mould
even if the CEO of the company of 50,000
people mandates that everybody use it
they will use it and a coercion and it
won't really work so the reason that
hype the hypertext is neat is that it's
very own constraining it allows lots of
turbulence flexibility now the second
observation is that when you look at
their agreement under which information
is passed from one person to another or
anything else for that matter goods
cornflakes but when you buy cornflakes
you think that you you think at the
first level that there is an exchange
where my money goes in one direction and
cornflakes go in the other direction but
in fact what you're getting is you're
getting the conflicts and on the packet
there's an UPC barcode which if you send
it in it'll get you a hundred American
Airlines free for proof miles it'll get
you you can send it in with ten dollars
and do the couponing with ten dollars
you can get yourself a free camera and
ten free rolls of film and you can and
if you combine it with a with the UPC
for that from a particular brand of
washing powder you can you can get a
free ticket to the theater so they're an
incredible number of different this is a
very complex agreement involved in
credit
number of different kinds of legal
tender we should be an illegal tender
which have crept in here so that if
you're going to allow this sort of
behavior to go on which marketing people
seem to need to do they seem to need to
have sixteen different types of train
ticket and 18 different types of
airplane ticket so as to extract the
most money from the populace then you're
going to if you're gonna represent that
in a system if you're gonna represent
the commerce and the agreement on the
network the network has to be extremely
flexible so that when you pass
information from one person to another
basically you have to be able to pass an
arbitrary complicated expression of the
license terms and I mean even when you
buy it so think of the video what is it
really what do you get the right to do
when you take a video home for the video
store it doesn't have a complex license
on it but you get the understanding that
you can show it and the reasonable term
as long as you're not on a coach or an
oil rig to people who are wearing your
family well say in your house the number
of people who can reasonably cluster
around a television and things like that
and you've got and it's reasonable to
wash it twice as well as long as you get
it back by the day if you try to write
that sort of thing down unless it gets
frightfully complicated if you don't
write it down in a lisp then and that
you send the thing over a network and it
sits there on a proxy server and it's
cached and then somebody else asks for
the thing this is a video this is
serious network traffic so the proxy
server is very interested to know
whether it can give you a copy if it
doesn't understand the License Agreement
because it can't read it it can't work
out whether it can give it to you for
free or B give it to you and charge you
a certain amount and pass them pass them
the cash back so in fact this is a
really big hairy problem in fact solving
that brought in solving that problem the
mayor many if you can find a
sufficiently powerful solution you may
solve a whole lot of other problems
accidentally given the fact that this is
very complicated I think we should get
off the topic and go to another one
otherwise I'm afraid we'll be stuck with
this very interesting one for the
remainder of the period Roger I'm Roger
Bloomberg and this is a question for
each of you if you'd like to answer as
you know in Bush's essay he cites meant
disappearance of Mendel's paper as a
catastrophe that in reforming modes of
communication and transmission one must
avoid so I'd like to ask each of you to
speculate about the future of reforms
and modes of communication and
transmission what catastrophes should we
avoid microphone so I'll say very
briefly
basically I see I see ours is an age of
information loss and as as as we
digitized more and more the formats get
crazier and crazier I've heard that NASA
actually has a a job designation called
data archaeologists and the great
problem of being able to see the same
document twice years apart is it's it's
very important to be able to see it the
same way I'll tell us very quickly when
I was editing creative computing
magazine I saw a great article on small
talk that I wanted to run from secure
English journal and it was so much
better than that that piece that Alan
Kay had written in the Scientific
American which really ticked me off and
I was very irritated with Xerox PARC and
their attitudes anyway they were like
Alan so we got permission to to reprint
this article from from this obscure
English Journal and guess what it was
plagiarized it was Alan's article which
they changed every occurrence of the
word we do they thinking that this
somehow guarded against a copyright
violation no that was the same article I
had read several years before and I was
a different person when I wrote the
article the article had not changed we
said for we the day and what this shows
is the importance of being able to know
that you're saying the same thing twice
even though you have changed and if you
change and the documents change nothing
can be kept track of
[Laughter]
I agree that saving old data is a
problem I believe that there are several
task forces working on this I think that
one can be solved the problem that
worries me much more is the potential
for the loss of diversity in information
sources it is not clear whether the new
technology with very low cost for making
many copies of one thing will drive us
in the direction of there's one
extremely glitzy multimedia college
physics textbook instead of 20 easier to
prepare ordinary written text books and
I don't want to see the technology
change in such a way that we lose
diversity of information preparation and
that means we have to work on making
multimedia authoring easier and we have
to work on you know preserving symmetric
access to networks rather than let us
say Direct broadcast satellite for
everything early not necessarily freely
merging merging with low administrative
cost I'll go with unfettered I would
just may bring us back to that yes your
name please I'm sorry I'm David clawback
from Brown University I would just like
to bring us back to Vannevar bush he was
as you know an extraordinary manager and
one of his concerns was directing the
the efforts that he was in charge of
toward essential and and specialized
tasks what in do you see the world wide
web the internet electronic texts
electronic libraries if you care
becoming essential services in our
society and if they are becoming
essential services how do we justify our
taxation of them or how do we go about
funding
in that case which is something you're
already addressing of course well I'm
having the mic let me just pick a piece
of that to address rather than deal with
it totally generically because I think
every every instance of capability in
society can be in some ways to dress
separately or should be addressed
separately in the case of the internet
the thing that is really the the most
viable attribute there is the
connectivity that it provides in an open
architecture framework at the moment
that may change with more functionality
but that I would say is the basic
elements that that's there and I don't
see how that is going to disappear but
the form and shape in which it's
provided could change fairly
dramatically over time this is a
marketplace right now for services and
there are every instance where a
capability can be provided as a
marketplace service than the market it
seems to me we'll deal with those issues
as time moves on things may evolve the
parties may come in some may drop out
prices may go up prices may go down
parts of it could be subsidised parts of
it could be this plateful paid for and
straightforward or indirect ways but it
seems to me that at least at that level
what you have is a basic service that
that's out there in the marketplace now
there are areas where oversight has
turned out to be important this was
nurtured from really very little through
federal government u.s. government
efforts initially today the US
government still plays a significant
role in the oversight process but more
and more the participation in that
process has become broader it's involved
folks from the commercial sector the
universities have been involved from day
one
and involves international participation
I see that that continuing but the
participation is at the level of
ensuring that the process by which
things work is maintained effectively
not in the provision of individual
services people may want to talk about
your other point separately as well why
don't we take two more questions and
then we'll switch to mbone Eric my name
is Nelson and what I'd like to ask is if
there is another McCarthy era style
witch-hunt sometime in the future will
it be made more vicious by today's new
tools specifically with the questions
specifically two issues one is does one
leave a trail when one uses the network
and one is if information about you can
be probably information that is about
you can be processed faster by parties
unknown do you necessarily want that
well the criterion for my answering this
is that I haven't said anything yet
[Laughter]
please go on wait that's that's the kind
of thing that interests me a lot is the
long term impact of our social processes
will change and some of them can get bad
and I thought so
the only thing I look at is saying if
whether you get there first with the
good stuff that'll help you solve the
bad stuff or not and so I've really been
focusing all the time on how can people
little collectively trying to really
cope with the problem in a
straightforward way do it and it's all
been focused in domains in which you
assume the people are agreeing to
collaborate on it so the the copyright
issues aren't there it's out in a
salient way so so that therefore I've
said it and I'm not much good at
answering your question I think
I I came out of in high school I read
Fahrenheit 451 and and 1984 and the
space merchants and all those terrible
government - conspiracy kinds of things
and so I've always thought the
government was a conspiracy and when
when Lee Harvey Oswald was shot I
predicted the shooting of Lee Harvey
Oswald Debbie didn't I three minutes
before it happened and and so so for
four years during the 60s I was an
assassination buff and just sure that
the entire structure of American society
was controlled by some terrible group it
was so obvious I mean there's so much
evidence everywhere and gradually this
hypothesis has fallen of its own weight
because the number of people involved in
the conspiracy at a witting level had to
be in the hundreds of thousands so so
basically but it is certainly the case
that that there are new tools out there
that people are figuring out how to use
adversarially in new ways every day the
creation of any new tool creates a new
adversarial method perhaps just as the
creation of any new capability creates a
deprived class and a privileged class
people who talk about how are we going
to make sure everyone has equal access
to information give me a break
when did anyone ever have equal access
to information and how can it ever be
possible those of us who spend 48 hours
a day trying to get as much information
as we can are obviously going to be in a
different category from those who from
couch potatoes okay so so anyway good
question I think that this is really I
think it concerns a lot of people it
certainly concerns me this is all about
largely the import of my talk
civilization is walking a road between
the mountains of despotic potato ship
and the swamps of terrorism and every
now and again somebody feels that that
we're viewing one direction and drives
hard on the other direction how are we
going so how can we ensure that in fact
we sit stay on the in the green pastures
in between perhaps one of the answers is
it's making a sort of fractal society
when do the interesting thing that for
me the 10th ed
there is when there are quite a number
of people to have been in the conspiracy
approach was it ten thousand a hundred
thousand at that point you realized that
you realized that they couldn't do that
without you knowing one of them so in
other words who knows so so it's a
question of the number of links in a way
that if you if society is stretchered
not right then you also know somebody
sufficiently well who knows somebody
sufficiently well who know somebody who
knows the president that you trust the
guy or you don't or if it's too many
there are too many levels then you and
all the people that know you that you
know and all the people that they know
can all have the same conspiracy theory
could all be meeting in the woods doing
nasty mean of things with explosives and
seriously think that they're right one
more question
rosemary Simpson and this question is
for Ted you you mentioned the problem of
spaghetti webs and the all the issue the
issue of information programming and
alluded to Dijkstra in your talk and I
wonder if you could address that issue
what solutions you would propose for
enabling us to create better structured
hypertext given the tools that we have
now well that's again like like what
kind of spaghetti what kind of ketchup
do you want on your cow patty and the
important thing is to improve the tools
right now what Tim has given us in the
way of a dress ability of links has been
has been fabulous we have to go on make
these by follow-up all done again not by
directional because links can be
directional and follow a little from
both ends but and secondly transclusion
meaning that you can look at the same
thing in some of its many contexts and
transporation and browsers so
transparent visualization could be added
to Netscape or any other browser you say
just well keep the thing you're jumping
from on the left and add the thing
you're jumping to on the right and sort
of rolls scroll leftward as you keep
jumping through things isn't it amazing
that hypertext which has nonlinear
structure is stored by Netscape and
mosaic as a sequence you say back and
forward in this structure what does that
mean when you're when you're talking
about back and forward in time in your
history of this non structure of this
structure anyway so that trans parallel
visualization of transclusion are my
answers and and and it doesn't matter
what the question is the kind of thing I
think that Ted and I've waved at each
other across the frontier for many years
that I think there's more to it than
that
eloquently spoken but that there a lot
of tool changes and the things you can
do in there to make a different way from
moving around for visualizing what's
going on for constructing views that are
interesting and supportive and for
getting content conventions in the way
you structure and tag things so that
they're more useful at cetera so there's
a lot to explore and I think it's it you
know we it's not going to happen unless
there's a purposeful push just to try to
make a better constructive way in which
knowledge is dynamically developed by a
collective group and so but thank you
very much the ideas and let's switch to
mbone let's lower the lights a little so
we can see the question not yet oh I was
under the impression we had some things
queued up okay in that case somebody
else from the audience hey Raj questions
for Michael do you think we will get to
a stage where all the libraries will
stop funding the current 3% and I'll go
all electronic and when should they do
that you're saying when should write up
funding the current library systems and
go to all electronic digital libraries
this obviously is going to be a
progressive thing there are
pharmaceutical companies today where 80%
of their acquisitions budget goes to
purchasing electronic materials there
are publishers today where more than
half their publishers like the American
chemicals
xiety that have a paper tradition where
more than half of their revenue comes
from bytes rather than pages so there is
a transition happening what I am saying
is I believe that by 2010 most of the
information that is needed by ordinary
students and ordinary faculty members
will be coming electronically and that
will be the major acquisition item in a
library budget they probably won't be
buying objects they'll probably be
buying the right to access the object in
some way the issue is what is the
transition path namely those of us in
universities who have a three or five
billion and five million dollar budget
have to worry about how to do it without
impacting a lot of people and without
impacting students and what is the the
right transition path actually I would
my experience of the number of
universities is I know more library
directors who are anxious to move in
this direction being held up by some
faculty members demanding that the
library keep buying books then I do the
reverse places where the faculty is
beating up the library because it keeps
buying books every university librarian
will have a story of how they have had
to cut back journal purchases because
one of the one of the odd statistics I
tried to calculate recently is if you
plot the statistic books purchased by
academic research libraries in the
United States divided by number of books
published in the United States year by
year it's been going down steeply for 20
years it's now back to where it was in
1920 so every librarian histories of
cutting back journal subscriptions there
are screams from the faculty when they
try it after it's done nobody notices so
the answer is unfortunately fairly clear
librarians are gonna cut back the sorts
of journals that exist because a few
people on the faculty have to get tenure
and for no other reason that journals
that are write only and never read and
the the journals will go away and no one
will notice and it will free up a bit of
money for the
libraries to do new service and what
they really need is a way to do this
without the faculty members who have
been seduced into being editorial board
members of those journals from
complaining last last question from Stu
and then all will tell us where we go
next
as I was stew card so as I was sitting
back listening it it finally struck me
what was odd about all your
presentations anyway is that you all
assume a world in which things go
eventually some sooner some later into a
completely we go into a completely
electronic world and leave the paper
world behind as opposed to a world in
which we have a role for paper or
augmented reality z-- in which physical
realities are interleaved with
electronic realities pieces of paper
ted's cut and paste for example that
have digitally embedded urls in them so
that in fact they he carries around
linkages to things around the world or
paper tronic systems in which the the
computer data structures are embedded
perhaps in the halftone images of the
things that are printed out or or other
forms that are mixtures between the
physical and electronic world so I was
wondering if I make it well holding the
microphone I would say that if you got
that out of my talk you got you got a
problem with your perceiver because I
actually hold the view that paper is in
fact going to continue to be probably an
increasingly present component of this
system I remember all of those articles
about the paperless office and I think
that's as likely to happen as the
paperless bathroom I mean just
not really in the cards so to speak
and I I just don't believe that people
are going to be without paper I think
there will be augmented technologies not
other kind the duck has worked on but
that that give you the equivalent of
that if you want to carry it around and
you don't like the equivalent of a
laptop or something like that and it may
even be embedded in the clothing that
you wear if that's the case but I think
paper is gonna be with us for a long
time as long as I'm around to perceive
it
g-goodbye well I think it's one of it
there are some things you look at and
you could say it's inevitable and you
don't have to set the time exactly but
if it's inevitable you start kind of
counting on it in the future
and I think I think it's inevitable that
that we won't have paper that technology
will let you have you know if it's
because it's convenient and small it'll
still let you have all kinds of views
you can toss in on it or something like
that so I I think it's days it's doomed
and you know I just tell people I like
books too you know but practically
speaking I I can hold in my hand
something that has access to all kinds
of books it won't weigh as much maybe as
a book does and we'll have more
information accessibility to it and
flexible usage of it so I think it's
inevitable I love books
I have warehouses full of them and I
don't get to read them very often and I
would like to have them all right there
in a virtual surround because they are
there in my heart and everybody's
information environment is essential
their spiritual environment I mean your
books the magazines you read the the TV
you watch this is this is your sense of
identity and but for me for the last 35
years it's just been clear as as a
divine revelation as Doug has said that
that obviously that's what we want to
get away from and I have been designing
paperless a paperless world for 35 years
and I'm very comfortable with it and I
promise you that when you actually see
it
great but the other part of that is and
I'm not as I've said to other people who
bring up the bathroom metaphor confusing
an office and a bathroom I think it is
it is it rather deep question so right I
wouldn't want to go to your office and I
just what I did I just want to say
there's one thing I am very very happy
there's moment between to the men I
admire most in the world
thank you I love books too
I and when it comes to pieces of paper
to scribble on just just looking at the
hard way technology come up in I mean in
my office I have two of the biggest
high-resolution screens I could get
stuck together as close as I could get
them so that you can drag the windows
across and I have very little paper and
I must open fit confess at home I have
stacks and stacks of paper I feel quite
at home in either environment but I but
for scribbling on the for doodling I
think that whereas the reference books
you're gonna have to happen cymet
cyberspace the pieces of paper most of
the pieces of paper it's going to be so
difficult to find hardware which can
produce which you can layer pin on the
wall quite as easily I my feeling is
that you're not going to get rid of
people unless you can make virtual paper
in other words than this you can with
your hand just just pick and you pick
out of a virtual with with your virtual
reality glasses you can basically do the
equivalent thing you can actually zoom
with perhaps accelerated Mouse hands so
that you can just flick a hundred miles
and pick up a really interesting piece
of paper and flick it back scribble on
it there's goat into a wall and throw it
into the metaphorical wastebasket when
you can do that sort of thing then maybe
you'll be getting so that would to the
point we can get rid of my by Fox being
I think we should give a wonderful hand
to the panel here and to Andy
[Applause]